[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock a big development concerning
downing street parties this morning
could the prime minister be facing a
police investigation for the health
minister ed argher and the shadow
climate secretary ed miliband on the
show today plus we'll put the latest
developments to the families of those
who lost loved ones in the pandemic it's
tuesday the 11th of january parties and
the police new pressure on the prime
minister following a leaked email about
a bring your own booze dining street
gathering during lockdown
i'm live outside new scotland yard who
say that they're aware of alleged rule
breaches in downing street and are in
contact with the cabinet office those
who lost loved ones are angry
it demonstrates the um
culture at the time in downing street
and how they viewed the pandemic and how
they well their contempt frankly
medical first the terminally ill man
given a chance to live after trading in
his damaged heart for that of a pigs
he's awake he is
recovering and speaking to his
caregivers and
we hope
that the recovery that he is having now
will continue
as new measures come in on lateral flow
test today can we say bon voyage to
covid stopping our holidays we'll speak
to the chief exec of heathrow airport
john holland k to find out
the clinical trial that uses horse
tranquilizers to stop alcoholics
drinking heavily
just like a rolling stone we'll show you
the stamps that will celebrate the rock
icons
also on the program for you this morning
was sorry ovid energy apologizes for
suggesting people do star jumps and
cuddle their cats as tips to keep warm
this winter
and entering the gates of hell we'll
chat to the explorer who delve deep into
this gas crater in turkmenistan ahead of
new plans for it to be extinguished
[Music]
a very good morning to you a new problem
for the prime minister this morning
after scotland yard said they're in
contact with a cabinet office following
a leaked email suggesting a danny street
garden party was held with up to a
hundred people being invited one of
boris johnson's top members of staff
invited downing street employees to make
the most of the lovely weather and bring
your own boos one labour mp is calling
on the prime minister to resign and
families of those following the lockdown
rules who love lost loved ones are very
angry as john craig reports bring your
own booze that was the call five days
after this photo was taken from one of
boris johnson's top officials martin
reynolds in an invitation to a hundred
downing street staff to drinks in the
number 10 garden on the 20th of may 2020
hi all he wrote after what has been an
incredibly busy period we thought it'd
be nice to make the most of this lovely
weather and have some socially distanced
drinks in the number 10 garden this
evening
please join us from 6 p.m and bring your
own booze martin
now after it emerged that the prime
minister and his wife carrie were among
40 guests the pm could face a police
investigation
scotland yard says the met is aware of
allegations of breaches of coveted rules
at downing street on that date and is in
contact with the cabinet office
labor backs a police investigation and
is demanding the pm's resignation i
think he should go i mean there's no no
excuses and it would come as no surprise
that i don't think boris johnson is up
for the job but more importantly i think
he's lost the confidence of the british
public now with his lies his deceit and
his breaking of his own rules
mr johnson has not denied attending the
party you and carrie attend the downing
street party that was organised by
martin reynolds on the 20th of may all
all of that as you know is the subject
of a proper
investigation by sue gray
that's a reference to the whitehall
enforcer appointed to investigate
allegations of several downing street
parties during lockdowns in england
but bereaved families who've lost loved
ones during the pandemic are already
outraged people couldn't go to funerals
we didn't have
relatives and friends come to come to my
father's funeral we couldn't even hug
each other family members from different
households
it was it was an absolutely horrific
situation at the time
the pm now faces an anxious weight for
the results of the whitehall inquiry and
a possible police investigation his
future in number 10 could depend on the
outcome of both
john craig sky
oh we're joined news by the health
minister edward arga mr argo a very good
morning to you let me put first of all
to you if i may what we heard from the
then culture secretary on the very day
that an event was taking place uh about
an hour later on the 20th of may 2020
the very height of lockdown this is what
the culture secretary was saying
those who cannot work from home should
now speak to their employer about going
back to work
you can spend time outdoors and exercise
as often as you like and you can meet
one person outside your household in an
outdoor public place provided that you
stay two meters apart
so just to clarify straight off the bat
mr uh argo good morning how does that
tally with what happened
at downing street less than an hour
later
well okay um good morning we've seen and
heard obviously in recent days the
allegations about what happened it's
absolutely right that sue grey a very
senior and very well respected civil
servant is independently looking into
these i wasn't at any
parties i don't know um about these
allegations so it's right they're
investigated properly because as you
alluded to in your introduction there i
can understand we've lost in this
country 150 230 i think is the latest
figure of our fellow citizens who've
died from this disease so i can
understand
that with these allegations people will
be upset and angry which is why it's
right that the prime minister asked for
that independent investigation to be
completed at pace to get to the facts
behind these allegations would you have
accepted the invitation
okay i spent my may last year um talking
to you on various occasions and various
other
media outlets but pretty much glued to
my
zoom screen and making sure that i knew
what the regulations were not least
because i was a health minister who
helped draw them up
given that would you have accepted the
invitation
i wasn't
okay i wasn't invited to any parties and
i'm not going to get into any
hypotheticals i was clear about what the
well i think i was clear about what the
rules were at the time and it's right
that sue gray is looking into this
matter independently
uh the police said
at the time this is a tweet from the
police on the 20th of may from the met
police they say
have you been enjoying the hottest day
of the year so far it's important that
we all continue to stay alert you can
relax have a picnic exercise or play
sport as long as you are on your own
with people you live with just you and
one other person does it sounds as
though that is what was happening
in the garden of downing street the very
same day
sorry i i don't know um what did or
didn't happen all i've seen of the
report the email that was reported
yesterday and various sources quoted by
various media and journalistic outlets
that's why it's right that this is
looked into independently by sue gray
and therefore be wrong for me to comment
while she's doing that and equally while
we've heard um i think overnight that
the metropolitan police have said
they're in communication with the
cabinet office so given those
circumstances i don't think it would be
appropriate for me to comment on what
she may or may not conclude but let her
get on with her job with that clear
field without any
comment from ministers or others and let
her reach the conclusion she reaches
hopefully swiftly we've all seen the
email invitation it says join us
it's from martin reynolds martin
reynolds would only write join us if it
was from the prime minister wouldn't he
well i'm not sure um that's as i say i
have seen the email i don't know the
context of that email and i think that
you're you're making a leap there in
assuming and making an assumption about
the prime minister i'm not going to be
drawn on that i think that again as i
say and i know it will be frustrating
for you but i think i have to repeat it
because it's the it's the right thing to
do is that that's up to ms gray to look
into and while her investigation is
going on i'm not going to make comments
that would pre-judge or get in the way
of that
okay so the police were tweeting at the
time saying uh you can meet but just
with one other person police in
derbyshire
were actually putting up drones at the
very same time this is what they were
doing they were looking to see whether
people were walking on their own in the
peak district with or with other people
whether they were walking their dog
whether they were too close
and whether they were from the same
household were the police in derbyshire
going too far that day
well i think and i this is where i will
try and rely on my memory of that time
um if i recall that the derbyshire
police subsequently suggested it did say
that um
that maybe they had
gone too far on that particular occasion
but what the police were seeking to i
spoke to my own chief constable in
leicestershire a lot at that time and
his focus with his officers was to
inform and educate as the first step so
to intervene and talk to people if he if
their officers thought that um that the
rules were not being followed and only
as a last resort to take enforcement
action that way bringing the public with
him and his officers and i do remember
the conversations i had with him at that
time back in i think may late may of
2020. you may remember a news conference
that the prime minister gave on the 25th
of may 2020 in response to a question
about big groups gathering in parks
boris johnson said the only reason we
have been able to make as much progress
as we have is because this country has
observed the social distancing rules so
feel free to speak to people yourself if
you feel they are not obeying the rules
but the police will step in if necessary
and encourage people to obey
the law um do you had seen 40 people
gathering in the garden of downing
street would you have stepped in
well you're you're citing a hypothetical
there okay i wasn't in downing street um
i don't think i went to downing street
at all during that period of the
pandemic i spent most of it sitting as i
say glued to a zoom or teams screen um
but i think we all at that time we
remember what it was like um and i think
we all and i think you probably asked me
at the time um would i if i for example
had people next door or in the street
having a party or breaking the rules
what would we do and what would i say i
made clear that i might have
a quiet word but i'm not going to
extrapolate from that or be drawn on the
allegations at the moment they're being
investigated by sue gray so i'm not
going to i'm afraid
get into hypotheticals about that i
think it's important she has the field
clear to do her job to investigate that
to talk to who she needs to to get that
information and reach her conclusions
about the facts of what did or didn't
happen
if 40 people were gathered in the garden
of dining street on the 20th of may 2020
was that against the rules
well i'm going to let sue gray get on
with her job in looking into what
actually happened you're asking me i'm a
hypothetical i appreciate we've seen the
reports recently i'm sorry health
ministry
on the 20th of may 2020 was that against
the rules as we understood them given
the facts that i've just given to you at
the time
well i can set out to you what the rules
were and you can form your own
conclusions and your viewers will but
i'm not going to prejudge what sue wolf
sue grey will find happened on that
occasion so you're in a sense completing
two things the rules you're right you
played i think oliver dowden there who
was culture secret time at the beginning
setting out what the rules were but what
actually happened or didn't happen in
downing street is a matter for ms gray
and she will uh come up with her
conclusions having interviewed the
relevant people having looked at the
evidence and that she will then conclude
a what did or didn't happen and then b
whether um anything that did happen was
consistent with the rules but the rules
are as you set out i think at the outset
of this piece as oliver dowden um set
out in that press conference let's let's
fast forward then to the end of last
year the prime minister has certainly
said i've not got any mud or blood on my
hands at the moment there might have
been parties going on in downing street
i wasn't aware of them and this is what
he said in uh the house of commons at
the time
i apologize for
uh for the impression that uh has been
given uh that staff and downey street
take this less than seriously i'm i'm
i'm sickened myself and furious about
that
want to say anything about that
well i think the prime minister was was
right to apologize um for that as i said
i've i've been a minister in the
department of health throughout this
pandemic i've spoken to you a lot and on
each occasion um every day i've followed
very closely the number of people in
hospital the number of people who've
sadly and tragically died from this
disease so i can entirely understand as
i said people's anger and frustration
and upset and hurt at these allegations
and suggestions and that's why the prime
minister was right
to come to the house and to apologize
for that i think he did absolutely the
right thing in doing that and in setting
up this investigation
he says he was sickened by parties going
on at dining street it looks as though
he was at least two at least two of them
well again you are
citing something based on some reports
some sources but we don't know the facts
and that's what sue grey is going to be
looking at i i know sue great she is an
extremely experienced integrity
she will follow the facts and she will
report on what she finds and i think
it's important we let her do that job um
quite rightly you and others would quite
rightly be the first to say if i started
prejudging what she was going to say or
seeking to influence it that that was
inappropriate it would be that's why
it's important i say i will wait to see
what she says and if she finds any
evidence of wrongdoing or rules broken
it's important that appropriate
disciplinary action follows that
we've seen the photographs we've seen
the documentary evidence we've seen what
the met have said we've seen what the
prime minister has said we've seen what
the culture secretary has said rather
than the prime minister being sickened
shouldn't it be the public that is
sickened
well i've already said i can entirely
understand why these allegations these
suggestions these reports
will cause
great upset and anger with people and
that's why it's right that the prime
minister
because of the time and everyone making
huge sacrifices sadly many lives lost
that's why it's right that the prime
minister said he wants to get to the
bottom of this he's commissioned that
independent investigation but i'm not
going to
give a commentary on what ms gray may or
may not conclude nor indeed given the
news overnight that they met are in
communication with the cabinet office
what they may or may not conclude so i
think it's important they're both
allowed to have those conversations in
mrs gray's case to conclude that
investigation and make the findings
known
you're looking my viewers in the eye
this morning um
health minister nobody would have wanted
your job this morning
how can you defend this prime minister
what i'm saying is very clear i've made
clear as someone who's been a health
minister and as you know throughout this
pandemic um i can understand the
the hurt that these reports these
allegations one of course particularly
for those who've lost
loved ones yesterday i did what i
sometimes do which is walk along the
memorial wall on the south bank so i
know i can entirely understand the
pain people have experienced through
this pandemic and the pain people have
experienced through the restrictions
they had to endure which is why i think
it's absolutely right the prime minister
may the same he did and commissioned an
independent investigation into it and i
look forward to seeing the results of
that investigation that's absolutely the
right thing to do
and i hope that ms gray will report as
swiftly as she can
i haven't given you allegations minister
i've given you facts this morning
you have uh cited the email you've cited
um reports and journalistic sources
suggesting certain things it's important
that ms gray as an independent figure
an independent civil servant looks into
this and is able to investigate it fully
and has the feel clear for her to do
that likewise um that the police who
said they've been in communication with
the cabinet office again are able to
have those conversations it wouldn't be
appropriate in that context for me to
comment on those ongoing conversations
or her ongoing investigation we've got
to give her
the space to conclude that investigation
to speak to whoever she needs to and to
reach her conclusions without fear or
favor
when will we hear from her
well if i recall i think the prime
minister said he wanted her to conclude
this investigation as swiftly as
possible because people wanted to know
the answers but that is a matter for her
because i think setting an arbitrary
timeline um would risk um limiting her
being able to go where she wants to go
and pursue whichever lines of inquiry
but i know he was clear he wanted this
to be a swift investigation a swift
report to get to the bottom of
of the allegations which i know is what
the public would want to
and do you feel it's now right that the
police are involved
well i've seen saw the reply you saw the
report overnight saying that they were
in communication with the cabinet office
um i shouldn't comment further that's a
matter for the police um but they as
ever throughout this panel they will
make operational decisions and and that
is a matter for them to decide um what
to pursue what conversations to have but
i do know that they've said they have
had conversations or in conversation
with the cabinet office
as i said minister few would envy your
position this morning um having to
defend uh what is across all of the
newspapers and most of the broadcast
media we appreciate you taking the time
to join us thank you
thanks kay
the met police say they're in contact
with the cabinet office over the downing
street party on the 20th of may we've
sent xingi down to new scotland yard to
bring us more shingi good morning
morning
tell me more
so we now know that the police are
the police are in contact with the
cabinet office something that they
confirmed yesterday after widespread
reports of though that party breaking
the rules and downing street on may 20th
last year after that email was sent out
by martin ronald inviting people to
bring their own bottles and enjoy the
warm weather in the garden of 10 downing
street according to allegations and of
course england was under strict lockdown
measures at the time the party took
place which is why there is so much fury
about what has happened at the time you
could only meet one other member from
another household outside and you had to
stay two meters apart but on the same
day the metropolitan police even tweeted
a message reinforcing those restrictions
they said that you can relax you can
have a picnic exercise or play sport as
long as you are on your own or with
people who you live with or just you and
one other person even on the same day
oliver dowden the then culture secretary
spoke at downing street saying the same
thing making sure that people stuck to
those rules but at the same time that
email was being sent out and a number of
people are understandably furious number
10 have refused to comment so far
they're simply saying they want sue grey
that senior civil servant to complete
her investigation into lockdown breaches
before they say anything further
okay for now thank you
see how this morning's papers are
covering that party should we starting
with a guardian says there's fury over
it with over 100 people sent invites
the metro calls it
downing it street and notes the prime
minister and his wife carrie both
attended according to reports
the email was an invite you do to what
you like in the words of the express
and the express urging the prime
minister to end what it calls the party
gate
farce following
the revelations
still to come on the program for you
what do labor make of the most recent
dining street party revelations we'll
find out with the shadow climate change
secretary ed miliband a little later
we hear from a former advisor to
vladimir putin as tensions rise between
russia and the ukraine
on our health first date can we say bon
voyage to kovid's stopping our holidays
we'll speak to the chief exec of
heathrow airport john holland k to find
out
[Music]
in other news a terminally ill man has
been given a chance of life after
doctors replaced his heart with a
genetically modified pigs
a warning this report from our u.s
correspondent greg milam includes
pictures of the operation from the
beginning
this is the heart that could give hope
to hundreds of thousands of people
around the world in a baltimore
operating theater the organ taken from a
pig about to be transplanted into the
body of david bennett the 57 year old
handyman was ineligible for a human
heart transplant his own heart failing
and so ill he told his surgeon he was
willing to give the experimental
procedure a try and perhaps make history
he simply didn't want to die
doesn't want to die
and
he felt that if he had no opportunity
and he was pretty well convinced by
multiple doctors who had told him he had
a fatal disease and he was unlikely to
leave the hospital because of it
attempts at transplants like this have
failed in the past because the patient's
body rejects the animal organ this time
the pig had been genetically modified to
lower the chances of that happening he's
awake he is
recovering and speaking to his
caregivers and
we hope
that the recovery that he is having now
will continue
and four days after it began beating
inside mr bennett it is still going he's
now breathing on his own it is a game
changer because
you know now
we will have these organs readily
available if this works and you know and
i hope it will work
doctors say the next few weeks will be
critical for mr bennett and for whether
a quest that's gone on for decades
finding an answer to the chronic
shortage of human organs for transplant
could at last be solved
they say this is a first tentative step
but one towards the day when the world
isn't limited by the supply of human
organs and an end to the years those
waiting have to endure greg milam sky
news los angeles
looking at some of today's other
headlines reena and we'll start with a
story that we warn you some viewers may
find very distressing
an 18 year old u.s woman was caught on
camera throwing her newborn baby into a
refuse disposal skip along the texas
border
alexis avila was charged with attempted
murder and child abuse after her son was
fined by a group of people more than six
hours after being abandoned
but luck was on his side as a group of
people searching bins happened upon the
infant in a black bag after initially
mistaking him for an animal the owner of
the skip joe imbriali says the act
was evil
i said what is it we are looking for
and she goes we're looking for somebody
that dumped a black garbage bag in your
dumpster
and i turned around and said please
don't tell me it was a baby who does it
that is evil that is just
i i don't have words for
looking at the latest covet data in the
uk for you now and there were 142
224 new cases of coronavirus reported on
monday 77 more deaths taking the number
of those who've died within 28 days of a
positive covet test to a hundred and
fifty thousand two hundred and thirty
low doses of ketamine could help people
with severe alcohol disorders to stay
sober research from the university of
exeter shows that the drug which is a
powerful anesthetic for humans and
animals has been shown to be successful
when used alongside therapy
north korea's fired what appears to be a
ballistic missile into its eastern sea
its second weapons launch in a week as
its leader kim jong-un promises to
bolster the military south korea
reported the latest launch and says the
missile traveled at more than 400 miles
to a height of 37 miles at a speed of
mach 10.
after a fire in a new york apartment
block kills 17 people on sunday
investigators are now trying to
determine what caused the building's
safety doors to fail
it was this that allowed the smoke to
rise throughout the building leading to
the city's deadliest fire in 30 years
robert dust the wealthy real estate air
and convicted murderer has died in jail
his lawyer says the 78 year old serving
a life sentence for shooting his friend
susan berman in 2000 succumbed to
several health issues
i had more money than i could spend and
it didn't make me happy
she talked on the telephone with her
husband then she vanished
durst discussed his crimes and several
damning statements in the six-party
documentary series the jinx the life and
deaths of robert durst a show that made
his name known to a new generation of
people
in other news the defense secretary has
vowed that britain would stand up to
bullies amid fears of an invasion into
ukraine nearly 100 000 russian troops
have been gathering near the ukrainian
border but the country denies its
planning to invade we heard from the
ukrainian ambassador who says they're
ready for a fight
those hundred thousand troops are camped
on your border as we speak if they start
to move across the border what do you
see the next move be
so many dead bodies will be returned
back to moscow and kiev that's for sure
and whether he will use the the full the
extent of his might or just very limited
to show us and west that we have to get
back to the table of negotiations but
we're already at the table he doesn't
have to move if he moves we will be
fighting
we'll be speaking to a former advisor to
vladimir putin as tensions rose between
the ukraine and
russia meantime ovo energy has
apologized after one of its companies
made a blog post about how to stay warm
without turning on the heating
the blog sent out by a division of ovo
energy offered 10 tips on keeping warm
in the winter without turning up the
heating options included
doing star jumps to keep warm as well as
eating porridge keeping your oven open
after cooking
and cuddling your cat the advice was
called offensive by some mps as many uk
households struggle to pay the bills
under rising energy costs
this is their apology we understand how
difficult the situation will be for many
of our customers this year we are
working hard to find meaningful
solutions as we approach this energy
crisis and we recognize that the content
of this blog was poorly judged and
unhelpful we are embarrassed and
sincerely apologize
savion lead the heating this morning
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and rain over england and wales will
clear across the southeast today leaving
it mostly fine through to the end of the
week but with a risk of fog and frost
scotland the northern english counties
ireland and northern ireland are mostly
dry and clear now but the northwest has
some blustery showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now this year marks a very special
anniversary for one british rock band 60
years of the rolling stones and in order
to mark their six decade long legacy 12
postage stamps have been commissioned as
a tribute to the band current members
mick jagger ronnie wood and keith
richards have worked closely with the
royal mail to produce the stamps that
capture the band's history
let's have a look at some of the other
stories in this morning's papers should
we this is the eye
a lovely fiery sky captured on a beach
in the northeast dog walkers out early
enjoying the sunrise at whitley bay in
north tyneside
let's take you to suffolk where a giant
statue of a
man without any clothes on has been
distracting motorists it's east danglia
is the sun's headline with the newspaper
saying drivers in the village of yoxwood
have been forced to slow down as they
drive past the 26 foot bronze sculpture
and it's become one of the trendiest
hobbies since the start of the pandemic
wild swimming in this picture from the
telegraph 41 year old rachel whitfield
is seen taking her
365th dip in a row on year's day in near
freezing temperatures she's raised 1600
pounds for a lido near portsmouth we'll
be speaking to a woman who lost more
than 20 stones by sea swimming regularly
later in the programme her name kathleen
wooden kathleen joining us later
still to come we'll be seeking to former
british number one andrew castle to get
his take on the events currently
unfolding in australia that's come
[Music]
nine of our top stories for you this
morning calling on the prime minister to
resign after it emerged that he attended
a gathering in the downing street garden
with around 40 other people during the
first lockdown in may of 2020
the first of its kind cross-species
heart surgery that gave a terminally ill
man a second chance at life
and how a clinical trial may prove low
doses of ketamine can help alcoholics
refrain from drinking more
earlier i spoke to the health minister
edward arger about the latest dining
street party allegations he said he
understood why the public could be angry
hearing about the dining street
gathering
i wasn't at any
parties i don't know um about these
allegations so it's right they're
investigated properly i can understand
we've lost in this country 150 230 i
think is the latest figure of our fellow
citizens who've died from this disease
so i can understand
that with these allegations people will
be upset and angry which is why it's
right that the prime minister asked for
that independent investigation to be
completed at pace to get to the facts
behind these allegations quite rightly
you and others would quite rightly be
the first to say if i started prejudging
what she was going to say or seeking to
influence it that that was inappropriate
it would be that's why it's important i
say i will wait to see what she says and
if she finds any evidence of wrongdoing
or rules broken it's important that
appropriate disciplinary action follows
that
tamara is here tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock of course um how much longer can
the government hide behind this sugree
investigation morning kay well look this
is the most exposed the prime minister
has been since these allegations of
parties first emerged this is not press
officers people you've never heard of
having a few drinks at their desks
eyewitnesses placed the prime minister
himself at this gathering we've got an
email in black and white organizing it
it wasn't a meeting in which a few
drinks were picked up it was organized
as a drinks party only an hour after a
government minister had stood in number
10 setting out these tough rules for the
rest of us you can only meet one person
outside and then as well as this
investigation by sue gray which may or
may not lead to downing street
resignations you've now got the threat
of a police investigation they didn't
want to investigate before when there
are allegations of parties but now there
will be huge pressure on the met to at
least ask a few questions so you've got
at the very least the prime minister
needing to provide an explanation of his
involvement in what looks like a culture
of parties in downing street during the
height of the lockdown okay thank you
well the prime minister has um
repeatedly denied that rules were broken
in dining street during lockdown
have a listen to this
all guidance was followed all the
guidelines were observed continue to be
observed those were people at work those
were meetings of people at work talking
about this is where i live and to where
i work those were meetings of people at
work talking about work i apologize for
uh for the impression that uh has been
given uh that staff and danny street
take this less than seriously uh i'm i'm
i'm sickened myself and furious about
that the evidence i can see is that
people in this building have stayed
within the rules if that turns out not
to be the case
and people wish to bring
allegations to uh to my attention or to
the to the police or whoever and then of
course uh there will be a proper
sanctions
joined by a former government special
advisor claire pearsall who now sits as
a conservative councillor for ash and
new green in seven oaks in kent hello t
thanks for joining us
this morning um
how much pressure is the prime minister
under today
i think he's under enormous pressure
we've all seen the email that has come
out from his private secretary which is
quite damning inviting over a hundred
people uh to a party in a garden when
the rest of the country were on quite
restrictive lockdown measures so i think
that he really does now need to come
clean as to whether he was at the party
lots of people have said that he was
witnesses who were at the party
themselves said he was there so um we
keep being told we'll have to wait for
the reports into that but something that
you can probably advise us on if you
would please this morning claire is um
that that's the invite to the party
apparently sent out to something like
100 people about 40 people um attended
the
email was sent out by one of his uh or
his private secretary what sort of role
is that in downing street do they do
things like this without the prime
minister knowing
i would very much doubt it the private
secretary works on behalf of the prime
minister in this case so to send out an
email that says we thought it would be
nice or worse to that effect means that
the instruction would have come down
from the top so i think that martin
reynolds the author of this email taking
all of the flack and the can for the
email going out is wrong when that
instruction would have come down from
the prime minister himself
who do you think the wii refers to
i can only assume that it is referring
uh to the prime minister uh plus the
private secretary himself working on
behalf as a conduit of this information
on behalf of the prime minister
why
would they send out
uh an invite like this we have to
remember what was happening at the time
people were being stopped by the police
they were being surrounded by the police
for going for a walk with a friend
well i think that is a really really
good question as to why this has been
put in an email it does seem to have not
been thought through whatsoever
but what is surprising that it has taken
18 months for this email to surface now
it was sent to 100 people and allegedly
only 40 or so attended
but what about those people who felt it
was inappropriate to do so why wait so
long to reveal this information out to
the general public
what's the i mean you are still
represent the conservative party don't
you as a cancer what's what's the mood
of grassroots stories at the moment
there's a lot of anger around at the
moment it just seems as if we come
through one crisis and another one
emerges and there's only so many times
you can say look i'm here as a local
councillor i'm here to look after bin
collections make sure that you know in
it make sure the roads are fixed with
the county council
but people aren't going to buy that for
too much longer we are all going to be
tired by the same brush that we are
either in some way responsible that we
are part of the problem and that isn't
the case when you're a local counselor
you are here for your local community
so pretty stark tweet actually yesterday
from ed davey um don't know if we can uh
show it to our viewers um the leader of
the lib dems of course he says yet again
it's one rule for boris johnson and
another rule for the rest of us this
time a massive garden party at his place
while people were dying alone and at the
end he puts ffs i think we all know what
that means um how do you see the
situation developing for the prime
minister over the next few days and
perhaps weeks he is
losing respect isn't he
i think this is going to be an
incredibly difficult time uh be
interesting to see what is brought up in
the chamber today i know that there are
allegations made that he could have
misled parliament so we'll see if that
is brought up in the chamber and whether
the speaker will take them to task um in
that matter but this unless it is dealt
with head-on this morning is going to
drag out for the rest of the week and
i'm not convinced that he can hide
behind the sea grey investigation for
too much longer
and taking it head on what does that
look like
i think he does need to come clean
people are suggesting that he was at the
party with his wife and it's now time
for the prime minister to stand up and
say whether that was true or not
and if he was then what
well then i think the appropriate
sanctions needs to be made and you know
i don't wish to hide behind the secret
investigation as i've just said but she
is tasked with investigating it and the
punishments will be handed out after
that and i think it's appropriate that
we do wait for her report and i hope
that that will be quick and coming out
can you survive this and is it that he
had these parties that you know we've
seen uh documentary evidence that he did
or is it that he has consistently denied
any involvement
i think it's a bit of both to be honest
when we were looking at sort of the back
end of last year when the uh allegations
of other parties came out there was an
awful lot of anger but then we had the
christmas period everybody was
continuing on with their lives and i
should imagine that the prime minister
hoped that this would die down but
unfortunately to see now a drip of more
information of rule breaking coming out
i think this is going to be incredibly
hard for him to survive
so you think he may well lose his
position
well that that really is a matter for
himself he's got to assess whether he
considers his position to be tenable
going forward we are running into uh
local elections coming up uh mid this
year that's going to be quite tricky for
those candidates who are up for election
so it really is now down to the prime
minister to decide what is best for the
party and for the country
thank you for taking the time to join us
this morning thank you
we're hearing what labour thinks about
the latest allegations about uh events
at ten downing street in the uh next
hour here on sky news the breakfast
program meantime the governing body of
men's tennis has described the
controversy over novak djokovic's visa
as damaging on all fronts the status of
the visa is now once again in question
as the original decision still stands a
chance of being overturned joined now by
nicole who is live in melbourne for us
busy day for you yesterday um is he
going to stay is he going to play on
monday that's what everybody wants to
know the answer to
that's the big question right now
we really don't know we're waiting to
hear from the immigration minister alex
hawk we've been waiting all day tuesday
and it's now almost seven o'clock local
time in melbourne no word has come out
the government has confirmed though that
they're looking into whether novak
djokovic provided a false
information in his travel claims into
the country so when you're arriving to
australia you have to say which
countries you've been in in the previous
two weeks he said that he hadn't been in
any countries but it has since turned
out that he had been in spain
so that's what's being investigated at
the moment it seems to be delaying any
announcement so for novak djokovic's
legal team it's still in limbo he's
playing though he's on the court
training trying to make up for lost time
we've also had a response from the men's
tennis governing body they have said
that they respect all the sacrifices of
the australian people during the
lockdowns but that in traveling to
melbourne it's clear novak djokovic
believed he had been granted a necessary
medical exemption
in order to comply with entry
regulations they then went on to say the
series of events leading to monday's
court hearing have been damaging on all
fronts including for novak's well-being
and preparation for the australian open
so no real clarity on whether he will be
able to play in the australian open
which is less than a week away now he's
lost out on a lot of his training time
but he's now trying to get on the court
and make up for that
okay thanks very much indeed thanks a
lot joined by former british number one
andrew castle now hi andrew um even if
he does play what sort of impact will
all of this disruption have on his game
do you think
well i mean he's good enough that he
could probably win wearing uh body
weights and an ankle tag he's you know
he's that good a player he's 20 25 above
anybody who's not in in the top 10 and
he's better than that lot as well
he's a very determined and very very
stubborn competitor both on court and
off in any dealings that you have with
novak djokovic you know you're up
against it either across a net
or in a business sense he's got a great
team around him they've stayed patient
and they've watched this thing uh unfold
i mean he's one as nicole was saying
there and incidentally how good did the
river yara look behind her at this time
of the year when the skies are great um
you know australia heralds has started a
new year he always comes into the
australian open fresh as most of the
players do because they finally get a
rest after a long tennis here which
normally ends in november for them but
this certainly will have taken his toll
but after two or three matches
he might get a cruise through them and
find some form but i mean it's it's
interesting isn't it that the the uh
with respect to the story beforehand
about downing street parties that
allegation or any allegation of of
hypocrisy and one rule for them and one
foot rule for others especially when
people have been through
a bit of hell like we all have in
australia more than most
um they they really you know the public
really react very strongly to that was
no vank jokovic given special treatment
or not how does alex hawk now the
immigration minister decide whether or
not uh under the migration act to to to
ask or not or not ask but to demand
novak djokovic to uh to leave the
country i mean he's won one court case
but that was uh on a procedural matter
although the judge did criticize um the
government and said what more could
novak djokovic have done it was
technical it was procedural now under
sweeping sovereignty powers on under the
migration act he could still go it's all
uh all up in the air still
what sort of reception do you think he
might receive once he's on court given
as you said the uh people good people of
australia have had to deal with
very strict lockdowns even stricter than
we've seen in the uk
absolutely
um the reception that he will get will
be to be booed roundly i'd imagine uh
his security will certainly have to be
beefed up as well i mean this is taken
on a different order of emotion you saw
the scenes when he emerged yesterday
into that uh that that black limousine
and people were jumping on the car and
the police had to pepper spray those who
were supporting their back jokovich
around the car so emotions are running
very high not just in the serbian
australian community but for uh
australians uh in total look i mean i
would imagine that once he takes to the
court that would feel like a place of
real uh safety and solace for him and
let's be honest he's never been as loved
as his two greatest rivals uh raphael
roger federer and and to appoint andy
murray as well so whenever he takes the
court kind of you know he always likes
to feel the world's a bit against him
and he's got something to uh to to get
the adrenaline going but this will
certainly be a test for him but whether
or not he'll get the chance to actually
tear up and try to win these seven
matches in the australian open for a
tenth time um i don't know there's going
to be a a hell of a reaction to this if
the immigration minister
sort of flies in the face of the
sentiment of the uh original court and
kicks him out i i guess that will be
decided today
yep we'll have to wait and see andrew
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed for joining us thank you
thank you well we know uh djokovic
actually tested positive didn't he for
covid on the 16th of december last year
i probably took a lateral flow we all do
them don't we at least a couple of times
a week and people around the world have
been taking them for many months now but
what becomes of the used tests some have
been coming up with creative ways to
make the most of their lateral flows
like this rectangular shape one twitter
user arranged his used lateral flows to
recreate his very own stonehenge
uh david levin took to twitter to share
the work of his friend's cousin who he
described as a lateral
genius that's amazing isn't it and
finally one of our own our producer jj
made his christmas tree a little more
covey friendly by accessorizing his
angel with a negative
test he had been positive before that
we're glad he's better now and part of
the team
again
send us your pictures what have you been
doing with your lateral flow tests and
if you are quarantining at the moment or
if you're recovering from uh covid19 our
thoughts very much uh with you our
regular doctor doctor lloyd just got
covered again but he is still going to
talk to us a little bit later on so more
of that to come uh very shortly meantime
a quarter of cancers in the uk have a
five-year survival rate of just 16
and yet nhs data shows that early
diagnosis for these less survivable
cancers such as lung brain and
pancreatic cancer cancer i should say is
often dismissed uh bryony thomas was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer in 2019
five years after she first reported
symptoms she's with us hello to you
good morning how are you it's seven
years since i reported symptoms two
years since i was diagnosed
wow that's amazing how are you feeling
i'm very well today thank you and
delighted to be here with you
yeah we're thrilled that you are as well
pancreatic cancer one of those cancers
that people think that is a death
sentence almost as soon as you hear the
news what happened in your case
yes well you know they're not wrong um
the survival rate is only seven percent
for pancreatic cancer in my case i was
diagnosed on emergency admission to
hospital having been to my gp for over
five years with vague symptoms like
fatigue like bloating and
not very nice things in the toilet and
these are the sorts of things that
people put off going to their doctor
about they're embarrassed to talk about
it and medics dismissed so after five
years i went yellow a symptom that
couldn't be ignored i dialed one one one
and i was admitted on emergency
admission four days later i was told
that i had pancreatic cancer
so what needs to be done to diagnose
people like you earlier
there are two things that i can see so
the first is that vague and um
non-specific symptoms like fatigue like
um
indigestion like persistent coughs if
there's something unusual with your body
and it is persisting then you need to
persist too
go keep going and keep trying for
answers
for the medics who dismissed me and it's
it's not an unusual story i see this all
the time in our patient community people
have been going for years what i would
say to medics is that if somebody keeps
coming back and even a flicker goes
through your mind that this person might
be a hypochondriac i want you to think
could it be cancer because if someone
keeps coming back with fatigue keeps
coming back with indigestion something
is wrong and the answer might be a
deadly cancer like mine
okay um but we all know what's happened
as far as the pandemic is concerned it's
had a brutal impact hasn't it on people
being able to go to see their doctor and
also for cancer diagnosis is even more
challenging at the moment but i'm
guessing even more important that you
push forward
oh incredibly so i think these are the
sorts of symptoms that people dismiss in
themselves anyway and over the pandemic
they've not wanted to bother their gp
and for pancreatic cancer which affects
generally an older generation i'm i'm
unusual although it's an increasing in
incidents in younger people these are
the sorts of people that aren't
particularly comfortable having
appointments on video so they put it off
they don't want to bother their doctor
their doctor thinks oh it's just a bit
of indigestion they'll be fine and oh
they're a bit of a nuisance um and
you know people also are embarrassed of
talking about some of these symptoms and
so are doctors doctors talk to me in
euphemism about my digestive system and
euphemisms have no place in medical
circles
okay i am pleased to see that you are uh
well this morning and we appreciate you
getting up early to talk to us on the
program thank you
thank
you um still to come in the next hour
here on sky news my goodness me we've
been speaking to the health minister
this morning um and he was talking to us
about a party
that happened at downing street the
invite we've seen it inviting more than
a hundred people to an event in the
garden of number 10 downing street that
event was held less than an hour after
the then
secretary of state for culture media and
sport had spoken to all of us and said
that we could only meet one other person
in the open air this was in may of 2020
when the police were putting up drones
in derbyshire to make sure that if
people were walking their dogs there
were only two people there from the same
household gathering together the prime
minister and his wife it's reported
we're at a party a picnic in the garden
of downing street we'll put that to
labor in just a moment
[Music]
you